this morning in our series school
matters we take a look at something
that's unfortunately become a num report
normal part rather of life for so many
students in this country
active shooter drills Beverly Gardens
elementary school is right next to the
wright-patterson Air Force Base that's
in Riverside Ohio the school district
began holding these drills shortly after
the 2012 Sandy Hook school shooting
Beverly Gardens is also one of a small
number of schools nationwide that
actively trains and arms some of its
staff vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is in Beverly gardens
elementary school to show us what
actually happens in an active shooter
drill what it looks like from inside the
classroom glad good morning good morning
here in this classroom we're going to
see in just a few moments what it's like
to go through an active shooter drill
I'm in the fourth grade classroom of
miss Stephanie Thornton in just a moment
she is going to take her class through
this active shooter drill it's something
that sadly they've all become accustomed
to many of these kids have been going
through drills like this since
kindergarten but their parents have
never actually seen one the drill will
begin when the principal Kristie feels
makes an announcement and I want to
remind our audience again that this is
only a drill after the drill is finished
we're going to talk to the kids we're
going to talk to the parents and the
staff
[Music]
in your hand hold on girls okay quick
quick all right make sure you have
something in your hands all right boys
and girls we've blocked the door now you
should have something in your hands to
defend you there's no reason to be
alarmed
I'm gonna be right here to help protect
you now we just need to sit quietly and
wait for further direction all right I'm
gonna let the office know that we're all
here
okay
so let's talk to some of the students
about how this all makes them feel I let
you know that this is important I know
that your mom has spoken to you let me
get in here real close to you I know
that your mom has spoken to you about
why this is important what did you tell
you oh she told me that it's not good
yeah this will happen yeah and that this
stuff is going to take care of it good
yeah
who here is scared when they go through
these drills Elijah why are you scared
I'm scared because if something actually
really happens it could hurt me or any
one of my friends yeah
Samar do you feel safe when you conduct
these drills yes because if somebody
were to actually come in here we would
be safe because we know everything to do
so you feel a little better you're doing
them yes we're gonna talk to some of the
parents there it's here
many of them have never actually seen
these drills happen Arlene is here
Arlene you've got several kids in the
school district your son Gabriel is
sitting right here this is the first
time you've ever seen this yeah it's
watching this I felt very emotional
seeing what their real reality is day to
day and but I also feel some reassurance
knowing that the school is very prepared
and they do the drills and it really
seemed like the kids knew exactly what
to do yeah Lisa we just spoke to your
daughter Lila you are a teacher here you
conduct these drills but watching Lila
Lila go through it how does that make
you feel it's it's very emotional yeah
just knowing that this is her reality
this is our nation's students reality
and you know that we have to have these
discussions of why we're doing this and
Lily understands why now she does she
did not understand when you know we
began talking about it and now she does
understand the importance of it the
seriousness of it and you know we've
talked about current events and it's
it's scary but also being prepared as
important and all these parents here
have kids in the school district
including Jasmine who has six kids I
want to talk to the superintendent Chad
Wiens I'm Chad come on over here and I
want to just get an understanding from
you these drills you decided to
implement them in the wake of Sandy Hook
that horror in Sandy Hook why well we
decided to do this because the important
thing is is it's my responsibility as
superintendent to keep my kids safe
every single day whether it's other
people's children or my own children
that attend our school district and the
big thing about these drills is we have
to practice if you don't practice you
don't develop that muscle memory and
then our students don't know how to
react appropriately if you saw the drill
it was fluid our students know how to
react and they feel safe based on that
drill there's another component to this
which I think our audience may not be
aware of which is this is one of the
school districts that's chosen to arm
staff and teachers why have you chosen
to do that we decided to arm our staff
because it's just an additional layer to
school safety we realize that the Alice
training is great but it's not enough
our first responders can get here
between three to five minutes in three
minutes to five minutes so many things
could happen in a school and I'm not
willing to let that happen to my
students there it's been a lot of
controversy about this across the
country and in this school district some
people will say look you do the drills
that's enough having guns in proximity
of my child puts them at greater risk
how are the children how are the
teachers and staff armed they're not
carrying weapons on them in the
classroom
correct so we have safe strategically
placed throughout the building for those
staff members that have access to access
to firearms and they go through
extensive training I think that's a
misconception it's not that we just
allow staff to have firearms but they go
through extensive training in order to
access the firearm and respond to an
active shooter their job is to go to the
shooter they decided to do this as a
volunteer and they know that they're
willing to risk their lives in order to
protect our students here matter of
local schools thank you very much
so guys the reason we wanted to show
this to parents across the country is
many parents know that their kids are
now sadly participating in active
shooter drills just like the one we
witness but they've actually never seen
it themselves and so hopefully I mean
what we were able to witness here is in
than two minutes these kids went from
doing their schoolwork to barricading
that door and trying to protect
themselves so hopefully parents seeing
this we'll be able to take some small
comfort knowing that should the
unthinkable happen that their kids will
at least be prepared and guys I just
want to say one last thing before we
wrap this up this training is constantly
evolving and later this year these kids
will learn what to do should their
teacher become incapacitated thank you
very much I'm thinking ball is the right
word thinkable is right and even though
we all knew it was a drill it was very
unsettling to see these kids this little
having to barricade themselves and grab
weapons which are pencils and books to
protect themselves it's very disturbing
to see something so unnatural about a
fourth grader having to re protect and
into their classroom of students and put
chairs and desks up against the wall and
the door to barricade it right those of
us who had to do had duck-and-cover
drills you got onto the desk to see them
cooperating to carry the desk and I
don't know about the parents at home are
watching this for the first time but you
know it is very it is very emotional it
was very interesting for all of us to
sit and see how disturbing it was
because I think when we were coming up
we had duck-and-cover we had fire drills
but we never thought that we could
actually be possibly killed or hurt to
me we were going through the motions so
we'd know what to do but I never thought
even as a child that I could possibly
lose my life to me but what I loved
about what the superintendent said was
that in this world we live in this gives
them control this there is a plan there
is something to do in this world of
threats that's a really kids were very
articulate to now housing and I like
that I like that Thank You van and thank
you to the very well does well the
parents and teachers